[Musique]
bonjour je m'appelle Sophie j'ai 39 ans
je suis réunionnaise je suis ici
aujourd'hui pour vous parler de
résilience la résilience c'est
l'aptitude d'un individu atteint par un
traumatisme à ce redresser à se
ressaisir à rebondir je vous partageais
mon expérience
nous sommes au début de l'année 2016 et
comme tous les débuts d'années on est
plein de croyances de rêves d'envie on
se prend à rêver à cette nouvelle année
et moi à ce moment là j'en viens même à
écrire dans un carnet mes rêves mes
objectifs ton personnel que
professionnel
tout va bien dans ma vie je gère deux
sociétés l'agence immobilière familiale
et ma boutique de déco les chiffres sont
bons j'ai un grand groupe d'amis
beaucoup de copains également avec qui
je partage beaucoup de bons moments
mais le plus clair de mon temps je le
partage avec ma famille mes parents mon
frère ma soeur les déjeuners les apéros
les dîners même les weekends pour moi la
famille ça passe avant tout donc nos
limites pour ma famille
le 4 février 2016
vous vous souvenez de ce que vous avez
fait le 4 février 2016 comment s'est
passé votre journée
et bien c'est normal ça devait être une
journée comme une autre une journée
Manale pour vous pour moi ce ne fut pas
le cas
il est 7h du matin je suis dans ma salle
de bain je suis en train de me préparer
pour aller travailler mon téléphone
sonne bizarre qui peut bien m'appeler à
une heure pareille mon oncle encore plus
bizarre on n'a pas l'habitude de
s'appeler certainement pas à 7h du matin
et qu'en plus on avait dîné ensemble la
veille
il me jette ces quelques mots au
téléphone bonjour Sophie tu es réveillé
j'ai besoin de te parler je suis en
route j'arrive chez toi je bredouille
fébrilement d'accord puis il raccroche
à ce moment-là je me dis que quelque
chose vient de se passer quelque chose
qui va bousculer ma vie mon monde
enchanté
et puis je tente de chasser mes pensées
noires de me dire que finalement ce
n'est peut-être rien de grave
quelques minutes plus tard le portail de
ma course s'ouvre mon oncle car
j'attends j'attends son annonce tel un
coup prêt il sort
me regarde et me dit Sophie il va
falloir être forte ton père est mort ce
matin
tôt
je pousse un cri en réveiller tout le
quartier jure que mon papa n'a pas pu
mourir
je m'effondre au sens propre comme au
figuré
30 minutes plus tard on arrive chez mes
parents mon père est dans son lit et il
dort jamais
un arrêt cardiaque la foudroyant en
pleine nuit
mon père
cet homme qui m'a mis au monde qui m'a
conçu qui m'a éduqué qui m'a tant aimé
mon pilier le premier homme de ma vie
vient de me quitter
mon monde est en train de basculer
le chapitre du monde enchanté vient de
se clôturer brutalement
le prochain s'ouvrir et celui du deuil
mais il ne sera pas le seul
le deuil c'est ce chemin sinueux de
réflexion de prise de conscience parce
qu'on ne réalise pas tout de suite
d'acceptation de gestion de ses
sentiments et de ses émotions
rapidement des conflits familiaux
s'installe
les jalousies de l'enfance renest
notre pilule vient de disparaître les
places se redéfinissent et chacun
souhaite prendre la place qu'il a
toujours souhaité avoir
toi tu as été préféré tel parent toi tu
appeler tes plus aimé que moi toi tu es
plus que moi bref le jeu de toutes les
familles et quoi de mieux que le
matériel pour régler ce qu'on estime
avoir été injuste pendant l'enfance
alors vous imaginez bien qu'une
succession qui s'ouvre dans des
conditions pareilles et portes ouvertes
à tout
je vis mon deuil ma famille ne m'est
d'aucune aide
alors qu'elle devrait être un havre de
paix dans ce genre de moment
et pire encore elle est la source de
tous mes problèmes je décide alors de
m'éloigner de prendre du recul
une semaine passe sans un appel puis
deux et ainsi de suite je m'éloigne
d'eux mais eux c'est loin également de
moi personne ne cherche à me retenir à
ce moment-là le schéma est simple ils
sont trois d'un côté et moi de l'autre
en fait tout le monde vit sauf moi
des revenus des sociétés familiales
Jean-Jacques rune mais je gère également
ma boutique grand bien m'a fait de
l'avoir créé quelques années plus tôt et
malversations dans ces sociétés battent
leur plein se multiplient
ils en arrivent même
à me licencier sans juste motifs de la
gérance de l'agence immobilière que je
dirige
tu ne veux plus faire partie du clan tu
n'es pas d'accord avec nos agissements
alors on t'evince en somme on te renie
le message est fort et clair
effectivement je n'étais pas d'accord
avec leurs agissements parce qu'ils
étaient déjà illégaux et qu'en plus tout
était toujours tourné à leur avantage
en fait je m'aperçois à ce moment là
qu'il y a un jugement Sophie elle a
toujours plus que nous Sophie elle a
toujours gagné mieux sa vie que nous
Sophie les gens l'adorent Sophie a plus
d'amis que nous mais la réalité c'est
que oui je gagnais mieux ma vie que je
travaillais deux fois plus je
travaillais 7 heures par jour 12 heures
par jour pardon 6 jours sur 7 dans la
semaine j'étais une heure du travail
j'aimais ça
j'avais beaucoup d'amis j'aimais les
gens ce qui n'était pas leur cas
et les gens me le rendait bien bref la
famille me reprochait d'être moi
le monde enchanté était bel et bien un
mirage et il masquait les tensions et
les jalousies de l'enfance qui enflaient
silencieusement
à ce moment là de ma vie mes relations
familiales sont catastrophiques ils
viennent de me couper d'une partie de ma
vie professionnelle si pour qui est
important pour moi
et puis vous savez quand vous êtes dans
une phase de deuil vous prenez du recul
sur tout mais absolument tout dans votre
vie je m'aperçois à ce moment-là que
dans mon entourage amical
beaucoup de gens me fréquentent par
intérêt
pour mon réseau
et également pour mon mode de vie un tri
drastique s'impose naturellement
et puis comme un malheur arrive rarement
seul mon petit ami de l'époque que mon
père connaissait apprécier et donc pour
moi validé
et bien avec ce petit ami j'achète une
maison il y en achant cette maison il
pense qu'il acquiert des droits sur moi
et sur mon héritage donne encore touché
que mon père m'a laissé
effectivement le climat s'assombrit
quelques mois plus tard c'est la
séparation
et je rachète ses parts de la maison
mais non sans difficulté
à ce moment-là de ma vie on est en 2017
ma vie c'est Hiroshima
je n'ai plus de famille je n'ai plus de
petite amie
et mon tissu amical s'est réduit comme
une peau de chagrin
les gens qui sont autour de moi se
comptent sur les doigts d'une main mais
eux au moins j'en suis sûr
comment et pourquoi j'en suis arrivé là
ça je le sais
mais j'ai une autre question périlleuse
et mystérieuse que je me pose
mais pour aller où
à ce moment-là j'ai le choix soit
effectivement je reprends mes relations
familiales comme avant toxiques et en
pleine conscience soit je décide de
couper définitivement ses liens toxiques
et de voler de mes propres ailes
la prison ou la liberté c'est à ce
moment-là d'un trauma qu'on choisit ou
non d'être résilient
la résilience c'est le choix entre c'est
le choix qu'on fait de ne pas croire en
la fatalité
de croire que justement les malheurs
sont là pour mieux rebondir pour
construire un avenir meilleur pour un
nouveau départ
faire le choix de la résilience c'est le
faire le choix de ne pas s'abandonner de
ne pas s'oublier
et moi à ce moment là je fais le choix
de ne pas m'abandonner
pour la première fois de ma vie
je retrouve mon instinct de survie ou
plutôt je le rencontre
le deuil et cet état intérieur
désertique qui m'a réveillé cet état
cette instante survie
pour la première fois de ma vie je me
rends compte qu'il faut que je fasse je
me fasse passer moi avant les autres
dans ma propre vie
je commence alors un voyage intérieur
long je suis seule et face à moi-même
et je me regarde
j'essaye de voir la personne que je suis
et surtout la personne que je veux
devenir
seul au bord de la falaise je décide de
celle que je ne veux plus être je ne
veux plus être Sophie la fille de son
père la fille de sa mère la sœur de son
frère et de sa sœur
je veux être moi je fais le choix d'être
moi
je fais le choix de ne plus de ne plus
être par rapport à ma famille par
rapport par rapport à tout ça
je fais le choix de vivre par moi-même
d'exister par moi-même et pour moi
alors je fais le tri je frie le tri dans
le bon et le mauvais le bon qu'on m'a
enseigné pendant mes 32 premières années
de vie et le mauvais que j'ai vu que
j'ai subi et que j'ai incarné
dans le bon j'ai gardé mon père mon père
a toujours été un modèle pour moi mon
père était un homme de valeur
intégrité honnêteté mon père est
également un exemple en termes de
patient en matière de patience en
matière de sérénité quel que soit
l'épreuve en face
et puis j'ai commencé à déconstruire des
construire mes dômes des construire mes
habitudes des construire ma vision du
monde des construire mon rapport aux
autres ma vision de ma culture ma vision
de la famille ma vision de mes racines
bref j'ai fait un reset mental complet
alors évidemment je n'ai pas fait seul
je l'ai fait aider de mon psychologue
qui m'a signé beaucoup de bonnes choses
la première c'est qu'on n'avait pas
d'obligation dans sa propre vie et la
seconde c'est que de faire passer les
autres dans sa propre vie n'était pas
une option de vie pérenne
le reset mentale prend du temps et
prendre l'espace dans ma vie les
journées sont longues les nuits sont
courtes surtout sur fond de deuil et de
problématiques familiales
les montagnes continuent de s'enchaîner
ma famille continue ses malversations et
moi je persiste à vouloir me faire
respecter j'entame deux procédures
juridiques au tribunal pour me défendre
et dans le cas de ces procédures je me
rends compte davantage de qui ils sont
de qui je ne veux plus être je continue
mon développement personnel de plus en
plus motivé il y a eux et il y a moi je
me vois m'émanciper grandir mais pas
nouilles devenir quelqu'un de
bienveillant quelqu'un sans jugement
quelqu'un de saint
et au fur et à mesure de ma
transformation
j'attire dans mon monde bien bien qu'il
soit très fermé la peur qu'il soit une
nouvelle fois abîmée des gens
bienveillants et lumineux
je vois les choses de façon différente
alors non le monde n'a pas changé et moi
non plus c'est mon regard sur les autres
et mon regard sur moi qui a changé par
rapport à avant ma construction elle est
en train de se faire
alors vous devez vous demander comment
est-ce que j'ai trouvé
la motivation pour pouvoir avancer
la réponse est le pouvoir de la croyance
je me suis dit qu'il n'était pas
possible que mon père puisse me quitter
en me laissant dans une telle situation
en laissant ma vie dans un tel champ de
bataille que forcément de se traumatisme
et de ses conséquences n'est très
quelque chose de positif
j'ai commencé à faire beaucoup de sport
7 heures par semaine à m'investir à 100%
dans ma boutique mon métier passion j'ai
voyagé j'ai beaucoup voyagé et j'ai
voyagé seul uniquement pour des raisons
professionnelles et également pour des
vacances
les voyages seul vous permet de vous
rencontrer le voyage seul c'est se
découvrir soi c'est découvrir des
défauts des qualités qu'on ne se
soupçonnait pas et c'est repousser ses
limites à chaque fois
j'ai grandi j'ai continué à grandir et
ce parcours en fait à ce moment là je me
suis dit que je ne serai jamais seul et
je ne volerai jamais de mes propres
ailes je ne serai jamais moi si je ne
rompais pas tous les liens matériels
avec ma famille
alors à ce moment-là
je décide de mettre en place un schéma
lourd et compliqué
pour me séparer de ces indivisions
ce que je vous ai pas encore dit je
n'étais pas dans une seule indivision
mais dans deux celle de mon père et
celle de ma grand-mère paternelle qui
était décédé quelques temps avant lui je
ne me retrouvais plus face à trois
personnes mes à 7 les chéquier c'était
agrandi
de ces successions je voulais qu'une
seule chose la maison familiale dans
lequel mon père avait grandi qui lui
tenait tant à cœur il souhaitait
impérativement qu'elle reste dans la
famille et moi j'en avais fait la
promesse sur son lit de mort cette
maison faisait déjà l'objet d'un litige
entre lui et ses frères de son vivant
je continuais mon combat pour la liberté
pour ma liberté alors non sans peine
puisque les négociations dans ce genre
de conditions ce sont des coups bas des
chantages des pressions des tentatives
d'intimidation
mais je ne lâche rien
les montagnes continuent de s'enchaîner
et vous savez quel est l'intérêt
de enchaîner les montagnes c'est que
chaque montagne qui se présente est plus
facile à grandir aggravir pardon à
franchir vous êtes tel un trailer qui ne
perd jamais sa ligne d'arriver
et bien moi c'était le cas je ne perdais
pas de mon objectif de vue mon objectif
c'était qu'à mes 40 ans je voulais
mettre des faits de tous ces liens
toxiques familiaux
alors j'avais décidé que mon quotidien
ne devait plus être rythmé par les mails
d'avocat les qu'on se colle avec les
notaires avec les coups de poignard avec
les héritiers les règlements de comptes
j'aspirais à une vie normale et saine de
quelqu'un de mon âge j'estimais qu'avoir
perdu mon père assez tôt était déjà bien
assez suffisant à gérer
nous sommes le 20 décembre 2022
vous vous souvenez de 20 décembre 2022
de ce que vous avez fait
et bien moi le 20 décembre 2022 j'ai
passé un nouveau cadre dans ma vie j'ai
signé le rachat des parts de la maison
de famille j'ai signé ma liberté j'ai
signé la fin de ces deux successions
j'ai 38 ans et je me sens libre
et surtout j'ai honoré la promesse que
j'ai faite à mon père
alors cette maison qui tient tant à cœur
la voici
c'est celle-ci certains d'entre vous
l'ont probablement vu en se promenant
dans la rue de Paris
cette maison je souhaiterais raconter
l'histoire de la famille mais celle avec
un grand H l'histoire de la Réunion
histoire de mes valeurs de mes racines
et je souhaite tourner cette maison vers
l'avenir
dans mon chemin de reconstruction
je me suis découverte moi mais je me
suis également rapprochée de mes
origines
de ce qu'il y avait à préserver à
honorer et à valoriser
je m'appelle Sophie j'ai 39 ans je suis
libre
ce travail de deuil et ses conséquences
ont appris deux choses la résilience
vous permettez vous permet d’hériter de
vous et la seule personne qui ne vous
abandonnera jamais c'est vous alors
prenez soin de vous et si ce n'est pas
déjà le cas rencontrez-vous
merci
[Applaudissements]